in 2014 was a very interesting year for
the world economy we saw carbon
emissions still despite the fact that
the world economy grew now that's the
first time that that's happened in
modern history if you look at Southeast
Asia however carbon emissions are still
rising and there's been very large
increases in carbon emissions in
Indonesia and Thailand in particular and
their carbon emissions are seven times
greater per capita than they were in
1970 so there's still a huge way to go
in these regions before they're on the
green growth path is it all
manufacturing or is it as well the
infrastructure of public transportation
isn't in place as well to meet rising
demand of growing wealthier demographic
well so it's a mixture of factors and as
these economies develop and they shift
away from agriculture to manufacturing
and pollutions increasing over time that
this pollution should diminish as the
economies move from manufacturing to
services and as they move from lower
value added manufacturing such as
commodities extraction to higher
value-added manufacturing such as
production of electric vehicles and in
countries such as Thailand you are you
are seeing the government actively
working to increase increase its role in
insect to such as electrical vehicle
production so I think economic
development will reduce pollution but
government needs to intervene as well
and encourage the growth of these of
these greener industries what does this
all mean for economic outlook for these
nations well we remain of the view that
ASEAN is going to remain one of the
fastest-growing work regions in the
world the fundamentals in these
economies are still very strong and
they're relatively competitive in
countries such as Singapore still very
tax competitive and also a number of
countries in the region benefit from a
relatively young population so countries
such as Indonesia are going to benefit
from the so-called demographic dividend
over the coming years which is going to
lead to sustained strong grave alright
top performers in the region in your
view I mean we've seen some pretty
stellar
growth from Vietnam in Philippines you
agree yeah we think Philippines and
Vietnam are going to see the strongest
growth this year that they're going to
expand by about six percent in terms of
GDP in 2015 we think Thailand's going to
underperform and this reflects some of
the political problems in the country
and also the fact that a lot of
investment plans are taking a long time
to come through in Thailand so
Thailand's going to be the weakest
performer out of the major ASEAN
economies and politically on a policy
level what is the commitment to not only
growth but a quality of growth well it's
difficult because it is hard for it's
hard for governments to do these things
unilaterally if one country develops a
greener agenda there's always an
incentive for another country to carry
on polluting so I think what we really
needs more collaboration between
governments in the region to to work
together to address some of these
significant pollution problems